my god it is hot out is it not ladies
and gentlemen
heatwave here in Los Angeles yeah yeah
temperature in Los Angeles will reach
100 degrees this week it's gonna hit a
hundred Khloe 100 was it a hundred today
it's over yeah over 100 yeah it's so hot
that here in California the ice bucket
challenge videos are now considered porn
what are you watching nothing dear think
at all dear it's unbelievable
ladies dumb it is incredibly hot out
there so I'd like to take just one
second right now to top the show to
acknowledge the man in our audience who
is too hot to laugh give him a hand
ladies and gentlemen
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
Yeah right
he's a huge fan - huge fan huge fan he
died two hours ago it's gonna be great
sir you're gonna love it
all right Timothy Olyphant here
[Applause]
oh he's trying to find a client right
he's trying
all right let's leave him alone for a
while his real news going on ladies and
gentlemen looks like Hillary's running
yeah it is looks like Hillary Clinton's
gonna run Wow
okay I think your reaction says it all I
don't care I over the weekend she went
to Iowa that's what you're saying is
that means that she they think means a
sign she's running over the weekend in
Iowa Hillary Clinton told the crowd I'm
back yeah out of habit Bill Clinton
grabbed his shoes and jumped out the
nearest window y'all see the Miss
America pageant last night sure you did
well me too
we were all together remember during the
Miss America pageant Miss Nebraska
accidentally flashed her underwear some
think that's why she lost yeah Miss
Nebraska said if she could do it all
over again she wouldn't have worn
underwear that's how you win that
pageant this is good interesting news
from the FBI the FBI debuted its new
facial recognition software which will
archive the faces of tens of millions of
Americans every single day yeah this
groundbreaking amazing new software is
called Facebook
sometimes he's right
a writer for orange is the new black is
divorcing her husband after realizing
through writing the show that she's a
lesbian yeah which is interesting
because after watching that show I've
discovered I'm a lesbian thank you
[Music]
hi I picture you as one of those fancy
lipstick lesbians Matney diesel
Hollywood Nicki Minaj is in the news
Nicki Minaj says her high school will
not let her come back and give a
motivational speech to students yeah
however the school has invited her ass
back for career day
[Laughter]
South African sports officials South
African sports officials have ruled that
Oscar Pistorius is free to run
competitively again yeah shortly after
the announcement he was signed by the
NFL
[Music]
had to be said had to be said
you